el ecuador la crisis carcelaria se
agudiza con el segundo entrenamiento de
la escala nacional que ocurre en el país
nuevos enfrentamientos en la
penitenciaría del litoral al norte de la
ciudad guayaquil y en la cárcel de
cotopaxi cercano a la ciudad de
latacunga hasta la fecha se contabilizan
21 personas fallecidas por
enfrentamientos y 14 levantamientos de
cadáveres según informó la fiscalía
general del estado varios policías
heridos y 60 privados de libertad que
fueron recapturados por intentar
escaparse según informó el servicio
nacional de atención integral a personas
privadas de la libertad se produce a un
mes del enfrentamiento del 12 de junio
en la penitenciaría de electoral entre
pabellones en aquel entonces no dejó
personas fallecidas otro durante el mes
de febrero en las cárceles de guayaquil
latacunga y cuenca de manera simultánea
que dejó 79 muertos y 20 heridos y nuevo
amotinamiento que coincide actualmente
con las declaraciones del actual
director del servicio nacional de
atención integral el bonobo cayó ante la
asamblea nacional para analizar
precisamente la situación carcelaria el
mundo buscar yo seguro que no existe
seguridad en el manejo de las cárceles
en el país cuando apenas 6.600 14 mil
agentes de seguridad que deberían
existir
sin contar la falta de presupuesto el
segundo enfrentamiento más violento que
ocurre en las cárceles del ecuador la
comisión interamericana de los derechos
humanos y las naciones unidas ya han
expresado previamente su preocupación
por la situación carcelaria del ecuador
se espera que el día de hoy se produzcan
reacciones por parte del presidente de
la república guillermo lasso en los
últimos cuatro años el ecuador ha vivido
una crisis en su sistema carcelario sin
tener soluciones hasta